today i'm going to talk about machine
translation and
specifically about the attention-based
neural machine translation
how many of you guys familiar with the
deep learning and neural networks
just like raise your hand
and how many of you
work previously with the translation
okay cool
so here we're talking uh briefly about
the translation application based on
neural network which use the
attention-based models
so i will start by explaining the
previous backgrounds that you need to
know about the recurrent new networks
and then i will
go through the neural machine
translation and station base let's see
how how much time that we have and we
can go through
so the material of a talk as you might
know is shared on my github so you can
actually uh like me open is in collab or
in your local notebook and you can just
follow up the topic
uh and
feel free to interrupt me but if it's
not related to topic and things so we
can like keep it down and we can talk uh
later on about the questions
any
questions about the administration of
the tutorial or
the thing or
should i explain
more you can just like go to my github
and like download the material that i'm
talking it's actually referred to like
some of the
um
popular ones in info so i'm not
gonna
talk about something
uh if i will not break the wire about
the anything especially
out of the
main topic
so
let's
go through
uh
background
as you might know about neural networks
that we have some input uh like
let's say there is an image as an input
here and that is shown by the vector red
one
and you are feeding it to the neural
networks like the general ones that you
know
and you will get an output which is
another
fixed size vector
which is shown here by the blue
here if you can see
and
and these kind of uh
so-called vanilla network
uh working feed forward you will just
feed the input
as like a fixed size let's say it's an
image
and
you will get
a classification or you will get
a probabilistic
whatever you like
uh engineered on your network
but sometimes you can
change the networks to some sort of
uh
multiple output networks
let's say you have the image and you're
going to get the sequence of the words
as an output and representation of words
could be one uh hot representation could
be the spring
we're not going uh into details here
but let's say you have again the
image as an input and there is a network
uh that green uh rectangle over there is
the same network
which is um recurrently
updating
itself so first it will uh output
the first
word for you which is here
and then it will update the weights and
then
again you will get the second word third
word first word
to the punctuation
end of the sentence
and you can get the sequence of two
words as an output
here we call it one too many
or you can change it
to
sentiment on all things let's say you
have the words
in a sentence and you're gonna see
uh
the polarity of the sentence as an
output so you have the
words
together as in a stream
so you will input the first one
your sentence is not finished yet
network will update itself then
you will feed the next word
then the network will update itself and
you will go in through the last word
when the
sentence
will finish you will get the one output
as a polarity of the sentence
or you can change it uh in the other
type of networks like many too many if
you have the video
frames of the video you're gonna get the
frame with uh frames again as an output
or you have the translation in
translation you have the words in a
sentence and you will get the sentence
again as an output
right
and these are a bit
like the
type of networks
that
actually works
like the second image that you are you
can see here so there is a network let's
say rnn recurrent node networks
which get an input as an x and you have
an output as an
y and then the network itself
uh in each time
stamp looking at the previous state of
the network and
update it and it will go to the nexus
step so you have the
new estate
as in the previous state
given the new
input
and you will update it
till the end of the work
these are the
type of recurrent new networks that we
have and
this is the simplest
formulation of the network is it clear
how many of you guys understood 80
percent more than 80 percent
okay cool cool
so if i gonna like show them um
again with
some sort of other pictures
uh in each state you have the input as
an x
you have the previous state your
function
has your network has uh has some weight
and you have the function to update it
so you will get the previous uh output
you will update it
and you will get the new one and the
next step you will do the same with the
new
uh inputs
and if it's like
many to one so you will get an uh label
at the end
here
or or if it's like one too many you will
just put one input you will get the
outputs
in each step right
cool
the same for many too many
or you can actually a stack
different
weights
rather than having one state you can
have the three step
so three states can be
uh
again works as the same so if if you
have a words as an input this is the
english sentence and you're gonna get
the portuguese
translation
so in each step you will just like
update
each of three estates and then you will
get the outputs
right
there are descriptions you can just
follow and
so let's let's go like the um
actually to tutorial is
the background coding background coding
to not be like that's boring so i will
just follow it up here um i'm afraid to
run it here because it's not on my
laptops i will try but uh
there's already outputs here so i run it
before so you can run it by yourself as
well
so first of all
what we're going to do today is the
translation english to portuguese
machine translation model
based on the
paper
which is popular um
i guess it's
came out 2017
um
by luca chateau um
from google brain which is using the
attention model i will go through what
the attention model is and how it works
but right now
we need the data all right to work with
so the data right now if you can if you
might
and can guess is
the words right
the english words and the
portuguese words and there are prayer
right the
one sentence has the prayer of the
translation
and we have the data set of them so
here we have just like
is it okay
nice
so i will use the tensorflow data sets
um
and i'm going to use the one of the data
sets over there
and a special version because i'm using
the
some sort of
things related so plotting for plotting
tensorflow as always
and logging
so maybe maybe we should just ignore
this one because i changed the code
when i'm not using spicy over
so here anyone works with the data sets
objects in tensorflow
okay cool so
this function load is
downloading the pre-trained
models or like the outputs from the
tensorflow zoo so i'm uh here we're just
like uh
downloading the data
which is the tokens
we will use it then later on
and if i'm going to show you how they
are look like when you're downloading
them from the zoo
you're good it's really
well-formed
text
that you can work with
so if i will
put the stuff out of the
loading which i'm uh
saving them in
examples
it has training validation for this
specific data set so i'll
store them into variables
and each variables is the iterative in
iteratable
function that you can get
and get the
uh words and sentences on so how it
works is just like you can get the batch
and take one so it will shows the
first
three of the
examples
if i will show them here you will see
there is a portuguese and english
translation
so what i have here is the pt examples
and english examples
and i'm going to work with them
right
easy
actually it's not that easy if you're
working with the plane data but here
we're good
because we have these uh p per data
so any question until here
everything is clear
okay
cool
so actually um
the the thing i
didn't mention
uh minutes ago
is the
network itself is not working with the
strings right it's a word that you're
gonna input it to the
network right so you should represent
that
word somehow
for the network to understand so we're
we're we're
using some sort of
integer representation of the word let's
say i have a data set of
all english
wikipedia
so i will go through it and find all the
unique words in the wikipedia and it
would be dictionary right
i will say the first word is the one the
second one is two the third one is three
so instead of saying a
i will say one okay
so here we'll do the same
so we have to um we have another like uh
trained model it's uh actually uh
literally do the one i i i told uh just
right now
which is already available in the data
set tools of the tensorflow
and we will put the
english word in we will get the number
so you can do this like by your own or
here we just check using it because
we're just going to ignore that details
and like
going through the
network design and work
so here we download it and we're just
loading it if you if you're just like
working with the tokenizer you just like
put the word you will get numbers so
here is this sample you just like can
call it if you put all the for example
examples you will get the numbers
instance so this is the
english sentence you will get the
numbers instead of that so the
72 word is the one
in the dictionary and dictionary is that
all the data sets
and you can do the vice versa as well
right you can put
instead of token tokenization you can do
the lead organization okay
or there are like
different things you can put the id you
will get the
word
cool
so we load the data set we changed it to
the numbers as an input
and right now
we need some sort of
training tricks
so what we're doing here um
is the
array of an input because of the
techniques that you might know because
like all of you
rise uh
their hand about the training which is
the batch training so you will put
the batch of sentences not one
um maybe 32 64 and then after that you
will update the previous estate
here we have we had one sentence right i
just like append them together
to make some badge
so instead of one one sentence right now
we have like uh
appendi appended text
so good
so what we're doing uh as i said we have
the input and we're gonna get an output
which is a translation of the sentence
so there's a giant model here called
transformer
we shall explain uh
uh more
let's say we're gonna develop the rnn
right now okay we're gonna add some
stuff in
and
where you we're using uh this technique
to translation for for the translation
so um
okay here it's good
so i need to explain a bit more
let's say you have the um
long paragraphs of the
explanations
uh
you might be familiar with the gradient
vanishing in the networks
in the vanilla networks like feed
foreign networks
which is about
vanishing the gradients over there
and
uh
some something is actually happening in
these networks uh like rnn when you are
you have only one w right for for or we
have like a stack three or four four of
them for updating
you will you will see the new word
and and you will change the
ways based on the new words as in input
and when the
other
new word comes you will change the ways
again based on that one right
and the third one comes you will you
will
somehow
not considering the second and the first
one right you just like get the third
one and you will update the weights
when the first one come you will just
like get that and you will update the
weight
based on the outputs you you have like
consider labels and you will just like
update the weights and
uh to get the better output
then the first one and fifth one
but
actually in translation and the context
the word is related to each other
if i gonna say that
by statistics the second words
somehow uh
refer to the first one
and the probability is the probability
of the second word given the first one
and if i gonna
calculate the third one is the third one
given the second and the first one
because
the the verb is related to the subject
and objects
right
so what we're doing
is the some sort of
uh
masking based on the things i just said
so i don't have like something to write
here but i will try to okay i will write
it here
so you have an inputs
so let's say these are the integers that
words that you had and you're gonna make
some outputs right
so what we were doing like
second ago was like
when we were wanted to update these
vectors
we were just looking at this one and we
were updating the
output and that and this and the second
time we were doing the same just for the
second but what we want to do and we
like to do is when we are updating
the weights
based on this input
we like to look at it and the others as
well
so there is like
some sort of illustration like this that
we're gonna
also see the others
and when i'm writing them like this when
i'm illustrating is like this i mean
like there is three numbers here that
you can say which one is more important
okay let's say here this one also
important but the second
the next one is not important
right
but the thing is
this is the idea which i'm coming by
but this the thing is here
we don't have
the
next word if we are talking about this
word we don't have the next word we just
have the previous words
okay i can fit the next next word as
well but if i will feed the next floor
uh
something happened like
the same the same problem will happen
but
in the other direction the network can
be biased based on the next word because
it's already know what is what it will
come
so it can just like go and overfit on
the next word
so um
then
the idea of transformer
is the mask
which is looking at the previous words
when you're gonna update the current
weight
which is the
uh attention
like the basic
attention
uh things that you are saying attention
annotation is this is this vector
actually which says v
which of the previous
word are important for the current
updates
if they are important then consider them
as well
there is something else which i might
not go
diving
or
i might not dive into it but it's like
we need to look at look at the batch
like these three or the other three
and we can do is like
in
different window sizes let's say the
other one which is
the same so we have the same layer
as the mask and then the feed forward
neural network
this is the
main core of the transformer
and left side we call it encoder the
other side we call decoder
because it's decoding after getting the
end token we will just decoding
the inputs
cool
so uh we uh appended the text together
for the translation then we will make
the batches for the input of the
networks for updating so for that um
we've just like uh
mapped the inputs by this function
make patches it's just like applying one
map
and the map itself
um
getting one
sentence in portuguese and one sentence
in english
and it's it will tokenize it
to the to the numbers
and the other one to the numbers and
then
uh
return it
and we will do it in all of them
and
that's it we'll make like the batches
cool
to
address this
idea
what we're doing
is
called masking
let's say the mask is a vector as the
size of the sentence it it has one or
zero
when you multiply that
vector to this sentence you will get the
divorce in the one positions
so for there we we need to make some
mask which you can
apply
to this sentence if the mask is in a
size of
four you should just like apply it to
the four first one and then
second four words
so we'll make the masks here
and we will go to the next
step
in the
attention itself
if you remember the uh there was like a
mask then there was a feed
forward neural network right you should
connect these two together
for connecting them
there is there is an idea how
how
much
i should
look at the masks which which mask
should change during the training right
so let's let's say we have the query as
an input
uh maybe this one
and
query is the
input
we gonna find
the
key which is the
new
value
for the specific type of input which is
v here
right
so let's say we have the sentence like
these are the two first uh
words of the sentence
we have the representation of them
let's say here we have the numbers
and there is a query
which is the ways that we're to learn
based on the inputs
and
the key is the word that we are working
on the values or the other words
and we will just like
consider
how much
we should change the key based on the
input value
okay
and
we're getting soft maxim as always
and there is also the uh derivative of
that in the paper that you can just
check this is uh making the
training possible but this is the like
the
basic formula
so here is the example of the thing i
said
by the numbers
so here we have different
tests on
[Music]
to see how that size of the output can
change based on your configuration if
you want to change and see
how the outputs are
till here
cool
because we have time i might
uh
mention the
multi-head as well if you are
remembering that we had the multi-head
on the other side and the attention uh
simple attention in the other side
so let's say we have uh an output
first word and second one and we have
the attention
so we can have
the
different
attentions here
we could have
different maskings
the one
could be
consider
the
relation
of the verb to the subjects the other
one can attend to the something else to
the colors the idea is um
when you making the next word
it could relate to the
different areas right
so we can
one of these vectors could just consider
one of the concepts the other one can
consider the other concept
the other one can consider the third
concept
then we can have the difference
attention head
that you can see here
and
when you when you have this input you
you have the
concatenate of all of these attention
uh heads together
which is a bigger
mask
but
they're all independent
right
and
for that also you will change the
weights right
so the size of the weights will change
based on each each of them should has
their own weights right
so let's say this mask uh
has the initiative weights of zero all
of them and then during the training it
will change
basically most of the time we're
starting by the
random ones but
we'll changing changing it based on that
and if you're just like multiplying them
you will get these uh
outputs
i'm multiplying these two you can make
this out
and this is the all things
in the shaman over there
so this is our input
we will convert them to the integers or
numbers or representation
embeddings
which
any any representation could shows in
the
numbers that you can tokenize and you
can determinize
let's say we have different
heads
so
you will get
queries
keys and values based on each one
and you
will
calculate
the
resulting weights
and then
you have the
trainable weights that can shows which
one is considered
or how how you should change
how you should look at these numbers as
an input
and you will get this uh
output which is the latent space or
shows how you can use the inputs to the
output
one minute
okay this picture actually shows another
type of representation so the question
is why this x is the matrix
so this is
other type of representation it's not
like one two three or the numbers so
let's say we have a data set uh
only for
four words
so all the dictionaries is the four
words
the representation of the first one is
one zero zero zero the second one is
zero one zero zero the third one is two
zero one and zero
and the last one is zero zero zero and
one
instead of showing it by the numbers
we're showing at them
by binary like
one-hot representations
so
i'm just like escaping some sort of
thing i'm gonna just
give you some ideas in this like short
talk
uh and you can see uh actually it works
here
uh
so let's go for some coding again
so multi-attention
uh
okay
we're making some classes so each each
part is the classes and then we will
combine them together as an object and
we will
put objects together to make the
lighters
so we'll make the multi-attention here
same as what i
just said
so each of
q
and kw
queue
query key and value is the
layer that you can
train
like the interest layer you might work
with
before
and you can have difference of them
with the different size of batch batches
an input the
number of the inputs
like the size of the vector of the
inputs
and you will
dot product that one
to the inputs
all of the tensor
so this is the multi-attention we'll use
it later
so like here we'll say we need a layer
of
500 tool
so
the output of this one is the object
of the layers of the cross in the tensor
flow which look likes these and they're
all actually those products here
so and and then you would just like uh
apply the tensorflow training on you
will get the
learnable
weights on
does it make sense
how many people following me
good
that's good like almost everyone
so once we have this one we just need uh
some
sequential model as a dance after that
one right
and then we will combine them together
as in encoder and decoder so we have the
self attention we have another self
attention
uh
for the decoder
and also we have the feed forward after
that so what we're doing we'll just like
put the
inputs here and then we'll get the
outputs
easy right
so for that we just like uh
use the previous one so we had the
multi-attention
and the feed forward
so we just like combine them together
there's a norm here as well let's say
just for normalization of the outputs
because they could have
different numbers and output
and the drop out for the training
and the same
and we'll make the encoder layer here
and if you will um if you was looking at
them
that one is also has the layer size for
the dance
for the sequential layers over
and
that's still two here
as i said we can have the encoder
decoder together like that's one core so
we can have the multiple multiple of
them
so after
making all of these things
um
right now we're using an encoder and the
decoder
so we have the
encoder part and decoder part all of
these inputs are the
number of number of layers how many
encoders you will use
and number of heads
based on the previous class definitions
and
you will just combine them together
with
another training part
have the call function
how to use it
how you will just like this is this is
um
for passing the
values in claw in cross like if you
working with
and we'll call this
class right now the transformer
which was the first
illustration
i've shown you
good
so i can say for example i need one
transformer with two layers
each model inside has 512
neurons
and
the inputs vocabulary size is like
something it shows uh the number of the
matrix of the inputs like the other
dimension of the inputs
0 0 1 and 0 the one i said
how many words
this transformation can generate
between 0 to 255 or
how you are representing
okay the rest is training
and for that we need the loss and matrix
as well in tensorflow so you need a lots
of metrics so we'll also define our
matrix
and
how the last function works based on the
optimizer again
and
[Music]
now we have some
giant transformer class that you can get
everything
and
here you are you can
train it right
just the thing is also you have the
training step in cross right in each
step how you should feed the data so you
will say the training using the training
step
which has the inputs and the outputs and
how the inputs and outputs works then
you will apply the gradients on and you
will apply the loss and accuracy
and we'll define one epoch
here i guess it's like
20
if i'm not mistaken
or you can change it over
yeah i just like uh
change it to one here but you can like
train it more if you like to
and
here we have the
output if you just like add also
checkpoints in the
epoch you can just
save the model each
iteration
you can use it later
and here is the
train model
which
could use for the inference time
good
so
basically
for the inference also we need to write
everything again right for the
decoder parts
right if
uh encoder and decoder both of them if
you have the inputs
we're not
changing the outputs but we will
multiply it and then we'll multiply and
then
build that product
and then we'll multiply it again by
dense right so we should write it again
here
which we call it translator right now
so if you will put one module
transformer modularly
you can
have the
translator
how the translator works
getting an inputs
and the transformer and then you can
just apply the translation on
and this is the magic
this model
surprisingly
works very well
[Music]
even by maybe
five times training which takes like
five minutes
uh you can get
some outfits
which is kinda really good
uh
we we had just like uh one one epic
training let's see how is it um
okay it's not that good
um
i had like the train model over there
in my laptop but here we can wait five
minutes or you can run it by 20
minutes and you'll see the output which
is surprisingly
works well
for the rest of the time
i will show you some plots
which is uh
kind of interesting
so what we are doing is
let's say we're gonna see how the
attentions work
we'll get one
input
word and we'll multiply it by the
trained
mask
and we will look at the output and we
will see which one making the
higher number
and we have different
inputs and different heads
you can make one matrix which shows
which word related to which
head
and then you can make something like
this
which says if
and also also
you can have again word by word right
so you can see which word relate to each
word
and here
it's not a good uh outfit maybe i can
go through the github here
i might have the outputs over there
so i will update it by the train model
as well i guess there is no train model
there
so um
for example you have you have this uh
input
as an english english sentence and you
will get these outputs right
so and it shows like uh
esto as an output was related to this
and when the network was making the esto
was looking at these
and when the network was making
livero was looking at
the
book also the dad
but you can see it in the different
layers as well right
and for example here you can see this
part this layer actually
does nothing
maybe just looking at the previous one
like the rnn
but maybe this one
is considering something else
right or maybe this one is doing uh
like like this one is like maybe the
object of the uh of the sentence right
so for this one is looking at all of the
previous ones like
but for the other one is not
and you can do is like
for the different ones and you can also
save all the
translator right now
as an inference so you will just say
save the inference one inference
translator we can use it later
thanks